that's so good
so let's take a look at what you can get
away with this week it's pretty amazing
one man arrested after a mass shooting
in a south carolina mall they have them
there
in which 14 people were wounded he has
been released he's under house arrest
and must wear an ankle monitor after the
judge said 25 grand bond now there's an
investment opportunity i missed out on
ankle monitors
who knew that they would replace prisons
maybe nike or converse can make a
version that comes with one already
built in
thankfully he has been told not to
contact victims of the attack who range
in age from 15 to 75 i guess his apology
will have to be done on a zoom call and
speaking of zoom the perp can go to work
while under arrest just like you cat
guess who will be voted
employee of the month in that office the
hr department must be dreading his
yearly review
meanwhile in dc which stands for duck
and cover it appears dog napping is not
a crime-worthy
crime
a crime-worthy crime worthy of
incarceration
losing my brain
the feds chose not to press charges
against four men
arrested at an apartment where pablo a
missing dog was found pablo was taken
from his owners at gunpoint along with
firearms and drugs the four men were
released and won't be charged which
again will only embolden criminals not
to mention damaging pablo self-esteem
poor thing i guess the dog couldn't fill
out the paperwork without opposable
thumbs
you have that problem charlie
meanwhile over at the edna mahan
correctional facility it's a woman's
prison your future mailing address cat
there a transgender prisoner knocked up
not one but two female inmates
you go girl
and here i was thinking here i was
thinking a trans woman in a women's
prison was gonna cause problems
no apparently the inmates welcomed her
with open
arms
i hear
i hear they're gonna have the gender
reveal party in the laundry room the
gift registry is the prison commissary i
already ordered the tins of mackerel
that's what they sell i checked on the
commissary they sell they sell
tins of mackerel
and miss debbie snack cakes demetrius
miner who's in the new jersey women's
prison confessed to impregnating two
inmates one of whom is serving a life
sentence
and will give birth in early autumn
officials say the baby could be released
early with good behavior
that was a joke
just in case anybody missed it by the
way the father who is also the mother
but not the birthing person
is currently behind bars for stabbing
their
foster parent to death
god i hate to see what crimes demetrius
major is committing because his name's
minor
so a murderer and a lifer are expecting
if their kid's future was any bleaker
he'd be a democrat in the house come
this november this baby has the genes of
two criminals he or she will be the
first baby that when born to shiv the
delivery doctor who slaps it on the ass
and yes the media uses the proper woke
pronoun there to describe the murderer
who knocked up the ladies because not
doing so would be the real crime i think
now we used to worry about prisoners
sneaking in a file and a birthday cake
not a penis
but i admire this scam
think about how terrified these woke
suckers are they're consumed over
pronouns without questing whether you
know placing a biological male murderer
in a woman's prison is a good plan
but the idiocy is all connected through
wokeness apparently the facility changed
its transgender policy last year so now
allows transgendered women who haven't
yet undergone sex reassignment to come
in meaning that an inmate with a penis
can shower among inmates with vaginas
and no that's not a loofah
and you wonder why women are getting
knocked up in prison the officials say
it's a job hazard so what can you do
well first maybe cancel the drink
specials on ladies night and stop
housing biological males with females
that's a start
get them out of the women's prisons and
into the college swimming pools where
they belong
[Laughter]
so that's crime today
but let's just hope more criminals don't
figure out this loophole
hello help help i'm being mugged all
right all right break it up break it up
that's it pal you're going to jail
oh i'm sorry ma'am you're going to lady
jail
i didn't know emily was bald
man yeah she can carry it though for now
anyway
but you know here in new york i keep
being told things are gonna improve
right but a corpse was found at the
subway stop sunday morning that's the
stop i used to take to fox every day and
he wasn't the worst smelling person in
the car
down the block for me two men got shot
in a dispute in front of a pizza joint
don't ever make fun of anyone ordering a
slice with pineapple on it
maybe it's me but i keep feeling like
adults have gone awol ever since we've
criminalized law and order all that's
left are two groups the oppressed and
their victims it's the allegedly
oppressed who victimize but then use
their status as oppressed
as a shield the lunatics have changed
the language and change the realities of
life without letting the rest of us know
so we're living in a lab experiment
right now where the left tests out their
horrifying theories on us
before we operated on incentives and
disincentives but now progressives have
disconnected punishment from crime and
we're left with a civilization at the
mercy of the criminally insane
anyway happy monday
is it too soon to start drinking
let's welcome tonight's guest
he's an advocate for spaying and
neutering pets and some of our panelists
host of dr drew after dark in the daily
streaming show ask dr drew at drew tv
i bet it's dr drew how'd you know i
don't know
what if she talked any faster the
audience would start square dancing
outnumbered co-host emily compagno
[Music]
he's my favorite charlie after a horse
washington time's opinion editor and fox
news contributor charlie hurts
well jesus turned water into wine and
she turned wine into showing up to work
hungover fox news contributor cat too
dr drew it's been months it's been too
long yes i was worried about you for a
while i'm all good i thought maybe you
had transitioned and then we were in a
women's prison
it's a it would be an interesting sort
of uh move to make wouldn't it well what
do you think about this i mean you're a
doctor and there are experts who are
like aclu sued to get
transgendered uh women into the prison
knowing this would happen i i don't
think they believe this would happen i
mean look
people have sexual relations in prison
it's usually women with women now we've
added women with a penis and the problem
is the liability of pregnancy my
question is what's wrong with your
profession emily what is wrong with it
because i i feel like the the sort of
the
idea they have is that
all crime is mental health or something
and then it to put somebody with mental
health problems in a prison is the wrong
thing
let me hear as somebody worked in a
psychiatric hospital for 35 years let me
give me the camera all crime is not
mental health it is not there are
criminals out there you sound stained
while you're doing this i know crazy
right crazy that i sound sick
and there are people that are crazy but
need containment they need it it's what
they need right and you can deal with
that
with some sort of facility but not the
streets and not ankle bracelets that's
not gonna work i was thinking about this
the other day and
it's very strange that the idea that
somehow it's better to have the mentally
ill on the streets of new york where
there are loud noises and cars beeping
and crowds that seems to me the worst
place to be mentally ill and homeless i
would think something bucolic where they
used to have sanitariums you know out in
the hills people in white coats remember
that when you were a kid they added the
butterfly net
that's how i would solve problems guys
in white coats with butterfly nets
um i know there wasn't a question in
there i agree with you uh and dr drew to
your to your point yeah i agree with you
i think it's the extreme segment of
those attorneys so the the extreme
portion of defense attorneys the extreme
portion of prosecutors in name who
actually aren't prosecuting these crimes
as they should be right so do they think
it's a mental health problem and that
therefore and i'm all for mental health
problems being treated in a hospital but
they're not doing that either no right
what is their plan i mean i look i don't
know i don't speak for them i promise i
don't i don't i don't have i don't why
are you here emily
god i feel like i'm on the stand um but
what i i just wanted to say that you saw
an example of that when you talked about
you know the the oppressors using their
shield so the aclu yes sued to have
transgenders um be in the same prison as
biological women and among others the
correctional officers union staunchly
argued against it right they called it
they said we are going we predict
pregnancies we predict a whole host of
obviously health issues this guy
impregnated two stds and the fact that
the judge however ruled in their favor
there's multiple now transgenders in
there what i don't understand is that
there's a there's an element of public
safety of protecting our citizens that
somehow escaped the judge in that
decision right that when he said well
yep i guess the interest of fairness we
got to let them in but what about the
coda to that what about however
in the interest of public safety of the
prison population of this poor woman by
the way that one who one of the ones
that got pregnant her judge at
sentencing said i've never seen a more
depraved or senseless act of violence if
she ever gets out she will she will
commit something like insane violence
whatever so she was right
she wasn't she maintains adamantly she
was not by this yeah
she was into it the point the point is
that this kind of person
regardless if it was a physical rape i'm
sure there's some semblance of taking
advantage but that's who we're dealing
with you think she has full mental
capacity to make that decision now she's
going to be a mom in prison i mean it
all of this is backwards especially the
non-prosecution for the dog by the way
and that's also why everyone should have
a doberman instead of these little tiny
stupid dogs i have a little tiny stupid
dog
wait i want to get i want to charlie i'd
like to put you on her house of rest
because your hair is murdering my heart
all i can say is anybody
lays a finger on my dog
there's they're not going to jail no
they're going six feet under they might
have a party house
they're not there's there will be no
body found yes you feed them to the pigs
no but it is kind of amazing when you
when you uh
like this whole concept of consequences
doesn't occur to these people and you
know obviously the country is sort of
politically divided and when it's
politically divided we tend to try to
you know a rational response is to try
to understand what the other people
assume the other people are making
rational intelligent uh arguments and
you try to understand what they're
saying but this is no zone for that no
it's like you you you let you let
biological males into female prisons
what do you think is going to happen
exactly if i got convicted of murder i'd
be like i'm uh you know i would do it in
a second yes i would identify
immediately who wants to go to a main
men's prison yeah i would also identify
as a really old lady so i could get
other medications and things i would
identify with like so i need some
medical marijuana for my glaucoma i
probably need some percocets for my
chronic herniated discs i would identify
every illness before i get arrested and
then have all of them
does that make sense yeah i think no and
i think it would work i think i think
you could pull that off
they would build a special prison just
for you i want all of your unicorn
friends exactly that live inside my head
you know cat i think the audience knows
that you own a cat yeah jeans uh would
it hurt you to know that somebody could
steal your cat not go to jail
even though your cat is almost 40 years
old
[Laughter]
barely is barely not yet no he's he has
the inhaler that helps him breathe
exactly i'm serious so but uh yeah is
that just i mean
that i guess your cat is improper no so
with the cat yeah i mean he would i
wouldn't be worried about him because he
would just claw someone's eyes out he's
not a knife it's still your dog yeah
they steal the dog and then jeans
whenever she's actually jeans is really
up on all this stuff and jeans whenever
he hears another story about a dog being
stolen he's like i wish it would be carl
and then i have to say cheese you can't
say that he's right there um but yeah
it's also i that's why i can never
certainly go and take the dog out it
would not be safe for me to do so so
that's why cam needs to do it every time
well you know you live in a neighborhood
where it's there is a lot of issues
going on
and has it gotten better
no i mean it's it's we had we were on a
walk the other day and some homeless guy
was like going up to carl like crazy guy
out of his mind and
you have a dog walker yeah yeah yeah
this week
something about it's their replacement
to not even like go to jail that i don't
understand that you like obviously if
somebody were to steal my dog at
gunpoint i wouldn't be like oh that's a
you know yeah what could you press
charges that'd be like kind of a bad day
for me but i think the owner of the dog
i mean when you think they stole the dog
plus drugs and weapons i probably should
have
should have glossed over that and and
that's one of only two uh uh dogs that
were dog napped in dc over the weekend
really yeah there was another one you're
saying yeah
that's double that's a 100 increase
it went from one to two
no i think no but i startling no i think
no i think it's i think it's part of a
it is actually part of a larger trend
yeah you're getting money for it and
they're so stupid they don't understand
most of these dogs are chipped anyway so
the first time so you sell the dog for
drugs right and then the new owner takes
the dog to the vet and they they they
they check the chip the you know the
chip there you go well now you know
carve the chip out
is what you're saying you make me sick
to my stomach that's what i said
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else